very quickly i got a question um i think
this was from reddit the question was
does the glycemic index matter
with macro factor a lot of our users you
know there's in any nutrition space
always questions about carbs versus fat
and then even further into that
conversation you know how do we choose
our carb sources good ones versus bad
ones and so on so one of the things that
comes up a lot is the glycemic index
and i cannot think of
an index or a metric that
has been misused more than this in the
nutrition world
and i'll talk about the
little instance where there might be a
little bit of utility but you know a lot
of times we get this question about the
glycemic index coming from people who
are
you know generally healthy fit
exercising um you know they're consuming
mixed meals with all different sorts of
foods in it and they're like should i
should i be swapping out my carb sources
for a lower glycemic index value carb
source so before we get into the applied
stuff the glycemic index basically what
you're looking at is the area under the
curve they look at the blood glucose
response
you are in a fasted state usually a
12-hour fast they give you that food
alone so not a meal with that food just
that food usually 50 net grams of
carbohydrate worth of that food
you eat that they look at blood glucose
over two hours if you have a huge blood
glucose spike usually that means it was
a really fast digesting carbohydrate
blood glucose goes really high in that
initial period and the glycemic index
value is high and they're all
standardized usually against glucose
which would have a value of a hundred
so so it's this quantification of
relative to a standard in many cases
glucose how much does this particular
food spike your blood sugar in isolation
in a fasted state so that seems like a
pretty good idea
initially it came out to help people
with diabetes manage their acute blood
sugar excursions in response to a meal
and especially before they had i think
nowadays a lot of the insulin pumps if
you have a pump are like automated so
they can kind of sense your blood
glucose and then deliver the appropriate
insulin dose but um i'll admit i've
never
i mean i don't have diabetes and i've no
one in my family has ever had diabetes
but my understanding is that
there's some degree of calculation going
on before a meal in terms of like okay
based on this meal i might need to have
this much insulin is that fairly
accurate
i don't know but
anyway yeah that that seems very
plausible to me that's my understanding
of why the glycemic index came out was
basically hey we need to help people
with diabetes make some informed
decisions about not just their food
choices but also you know how are they
going to manage insulin insulin
injections and things like that so
apologize if you're in clinical
nutrition and i'm just completely
stomping all over that but
the shortcomings of the glycemic index
are numerous especially in the context
of healthy folks who are exercising a
lot so first of all the glycemic index
is measured with a set number of net
carbs like i said usually 50 grams
but that ignores differences in the
energy density of a food right so like
uh watermelon is kind of the classic
example
uh they're like here's 50 net carbs
worth of watermelon which is like so you
just eat seven kilos of watermelon yeah
it's like a tremendous amount of
watermelon and so then it has this high
glycemic index value but it's very
different from saying like here is a
serving of white bread and here is a
serving of watermelon like they're going
to have different net carb values so
that's one of the issues there
it standardizes net carbohydrate which
completely ignores the context of
serving size
another thing is that the glycemic index
like i mentioned usually measured in an
overnight fast
with a single food consumed in isolation
most of the meals we eat other than
breakfast are not in an overnight fasted
state so we're still digesting food from
a previous meal and then the foods that
we eat are usually consumed our carb
sources are consumed along with usually
a protein source a fat source in various
combinations and when you start adding
you know
fat and protein and different amounts of
fiber into this mixed meal it
drastically can alter the dynamics of
that glycemic response so all of a
sudden this number that used to be very
relevant is now getting distorted by
interactions with other foods in the
meal
and also i mean the glycemic index value
of a food can change as a fruit ripens
it can change based on the way you
prepare a carb source the way that you
cook it and the degree to which you cook
it and it also just doesn't tell you
about the quality of the food right so
when you're looking at a carbohydrate
source you might might be thinking about
the vitamin and mineral content you
might be thinking about the fiber
content the energy density the the way
your your gi system tolerates that food
if you're a little bit sensitive to it
the palatability of the food the
convenience of the food when it comes to
cooking and storing
if you get into coaching convenience of
food sources is so important you know
like you can have the best diet plan in
the world put together but if it's like
yeah i don't know how to cook that and i
can't store that and bring it to work
the whole thing is useless
and then of course the cost of a food is
important as well so the glycemic index
doesn't really tell you anything about
those things and in my opinion those are
some of the most important things to
consider when you're evaluating a
carbohydrate source
so um you know they have come out like
after the glycemic index they came out
with the glycemic load which i'm pretty
sure
if i'm not mistaken i believe the whole
idea with the glycemic load was to
account for that issue with
standardizing the net carb content i
think glycemic load takes in account the
kind of standard serving size in
addition to like you know the glycemic
response so the glycemic load is a
little bit of a step up from the
glycemic index but it doesn't come
anywhere close to solving
all the other problems associated with
the metrics so
when i'm dealing with someone who is not
diabetic who is generally healthy
exercising things like that and they ask
about glycemic index my response is it's
just really not worth worrying about
um
the uh
in all my years of coaching
you know i i don't do diabetes
management which is why i know so little
about it i'm actually proud to not know
about it because
i shouldn't yeah if i'm getting in there
like pretending to be the armchair
diabetes counselor like
no that's not what i'm here for yeah um
so like you know i don't do diabetes
management it's a critically important
thing it's just not my expertise and i
leave it to the people who are good at
it so my caveat is if you're working
with a medical practitioner
they you know and they know your medical
situation way better than i do and
they're telling you to be mindful of
these different metrics with your carb
choices of course if you're under
medical supervision working with a
practitioner take their advice but i can
tell you that outside the context of
diabetes where i do my work i've never
once considered or advise someone to put
a lot of thought into the glycemic index
it is a very very limited metric that
has very limited utility outside of of
those clinical applications